[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ce set
sports sur tv 60,18 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce à magazine football le quart de
finale de coupe de france bergerac
versailles est programmée ce mercredi à
périgueux nous avons suivi les
versailles et sur la dernière semaine
reportage à suivre brügg be l'union
rugby centre 60,18 s'est imposé sur son
tas d'autres vitry ce dimanche une
victoire qui permet au club de remonter
au classement du championnat de division
honneur le résumé équitation coup de
projecteur aujourd'hui sur christopher
six médailles de bronze aux jeux
olympiques de tokyo cet été ce sera
notre module découverte l'actualité
sportive c'est maintenant sur tb 78
je vous le disais à dans les titres on
va commencer par du football versailles
affrontera à bergerac ce mercredi en
quarts de finale de la coupe de france
la rencontre s'annonce bouillante entre
les deux équipes de nationale 2 nous
avons suivi dé versailles et sur cette
dernière semaine des images de grégory
canale et bixente mérian santisteva
lundi 31 janvier le petit poucet
versailles est fixé sur son sort le club
yvelinois affrontera l'extérieur
bergerac en quarts de finale de la coupe
de france un autre pensionnaire du
championnat de nationale 2 un adversaire
pas forcément espérer au-delà de jouer
bergerac on est surtout triste de bord
ou souvent pour notre public oh ça reste
un match de coupe quand même mais c'est
surtout une place qui jouant pour la
demi finale et on va tout donner de
façon on se dit que tout est possible
pour aller en demi finale mais avant de
penser à ce match historique pour le
club versailles et les hommes de
l'entraîneur youssef chibi reçoivent
guingamp au stade mob auront l'occasion
de préparer au mieux le match de coupe
cette 17e journée de nationale 2 débute
bien pour les joueurs locaux et que
cette magnifique frappe de la recrue
hivernale johan brun la 17e minute de
jeu 1-0
tu t'en prends ma chance hein après le
gardien une fin un petit cadeau aussi
parce qu'il est sur la trajectoire et
xei seront un peu j'ai pris ma chance ça
m'a réussi mais la machine se grippe
guingamp égalise sur cette action juste
avant la pause versa et réagir en
seconde période le club se procure des
occasions et touchera les montants mais
ne marquera pas score final 1 partout
malheureusement nous a manqué cette
qualité dans la finition avec un poteau
une barre des situations arrêté par
l'adversaire on n'a pas pour n'a pas pu
je dirais traduire le bon comportement
des garçons au coup de sifflet final les
yvelinois se projeter déjà sur le match
contre bergerac
c'est de récupérer voilà récupérer pour
jouer mercredi donc va faire switcher
dans nos têtes pour passer aux quarts de
finale et est tout faire pour essayer
d'aller accrocher une demi finale de
coupe de france va s'attacher à se
reposer dès demain pour ensuite ouvrir
la parenthèse coupe de france dès lundi
il se préparer au mieux pour cette
rencontre mercredi on a une semaine
assez chargé avec trois matches à nous
de faire en sorte de revenir avec avec
des points et du sourire
ce lundi 7 février avant dernier
entraînement au stade de porchefontaine
avant le grand départ pour périgueux
sous le soleil dans une ambiance
détendue mais studieuse le staff est
revenu sur le match de ce week-end
contre guingamp avant de procéder à un
décrassage les jours sont pas encore
dans le dans le stress aidant et dans la
préparation et la concentration du match
non c'est un peu oui c'est un peu une
une remise en jambes une un entraînement
un peu ludique pour récupérer du match
de samedi et puis se préparer dans la
bonne humeur des jeux
au match qui nous attend donc heureux et
c'est une un petit intermède entre entre
deux matches l'occasion également pour
les joueurs de se mettre dans leur bulle
face à l'engouement médiatique d'un tel
événement cinq ans ont progressivement
après moi je sais pas je vais pas aller
marcher dans toutes les villes de me
rendre compte de l'engouement mais en
tout cas au niveau de mes proches mais
je sens qu'il ya de l'engouement qui met
donc quand vous voyez sur les arrêts de
bus et même des affiches un peu par
rapport aux coûts moi j'étais de coupe
de france donc ouais ça monte
progressivement et on va essayer de
faire perdurer cette cet engouement les
versailles et partiront ce mardi 8
février en train direction bordeaux il
prendra ensuite un bus pour aller à
périgueux un périple avec un objectif en
tête marquer encore un peu plus
l'histoire des yvelines jamais un club
du département n'avait atteint un quart
de finale de coupe de france
versa et va-t-il l'emporter contre
bergerac ce mercredi à 18h30 nous avons
posé la question aux supporters
versailles et et on peut le dire esi
croire à regarder sur un match
comme ça les deux équipes ont leur
chance
maintenant
ben
ça sera ça jouera peut-être sur un coup
du sort je sais pas une victoire de
versailles aux prolongations je verrai
peut-être un deux un pour versailles
serré et un petit but de joe cole à 80
8e débordements on y croit personne
après combien d'êtres 3-1 et on espère
nous aussi une victoire de versailles on
va maintenant parler à rugby l'union
rugby centre 78 recevait vitry ce
week-end dans le championnat de division
honneur un match équilibré sur le papier
qui s'est soldée par une très belle
victoire des yvelinois le résumé du
match à montage de xavier jaglin
des conditions climatiques anglo saxon
pour ce jeune de division honneur union
rugby centre 60,18 recevait à montigny
le bretonneux le club de vitry à
l'occasion de la 13e journée sous la
pluie les yvelinois subissent dans un
premier temps les assauts des joueurs du
val de marne avant de se reprendre puis
de marquer cet essai c'est à 8 à la
pause c'est vrai qu'au début on va faut
le tendre quand même de travail un peu
hâlé défense et l équipe en face mais
après en mettant en place notre jeu mais
on a su les mettre en difficulté puis au
fur et à mesure qu'on soir notre match
en pratique au retour des vestiaires lui
verser 60 18 dérouler les joueurs du 94
sous l'eau et ne marqueront plus le
score à la fin de la rencontre est sans
appel 29 à 8 pour les saint quentinois
score est assez large mais bobby de la
navy à 30 minutes à rentrer dans le
match on a vécu mes défauts les fautes
on va moins qu est de rigueur mais là
s'il se reprendre et les consignes nette
applicable aux habitants donc ça s'est
satisfait on aurait pu davantage
puisqu'on passe presque 20 minutes dans
leur 22e donc on a du travail mais c'est
ça qui est bien au classement les
yvelinois se retrouve désormais à la 5e
place avec deux matches en moins de
bonne augure pour la suite du
championnat top 5 ou est ce qu'il serait
qu'il serait vraiment très très bien
pour un jeu de groupe ça serait une
quatrième place qui sera peut-être
qualificatif donc on va essayer de
l'accrocher prochain match pour le rc
60,18 ce dimanche 13 février à 15 heures
face au voisin vous interdis important
avec deux équipes figurant dans le top 5
du classement
on continue notre tour d'horizon des
résultats sportifs du week-end dans le
département avec bixente mérian santis
tebbane qui nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau sans mickaël bonsoir alors on va
commencer tout de suite par du football
comme excuse donnant comme à notre
habitude ça fait un petit moment qu'on
n'a pas parlé de mort pâte d'abord en
régionale 3 qui est récemment monté et
qui fait un beau parcours pour l'instant
le club l'a emporté ce week-end 3 buts à
2 sur le terrain de la réserve de phily
morangis avec ce résultat maurepas
s'intercale à la deuxième place 4 points
derrière le leader le gretz tournan à c
et k points devant le paris fc le club
est donc toujours en course pour la
montée en régionale 2 tout comme la
réserve du versailles fc 78 en embuscade
à la quatrième position malgré les deux
points perdus ce week-end à la maison
face aux mets sport b du football mais
américain maintenant oui troisième match
et troisième victoire de rang pour les
templiers d'elancourt en deuxième
division nationale score 21 à 7 face aux
corsaires d'evry les templiers
poursuivre leur rêve de retrouver
l'élite il leur reste dix journées de
championnat pour cela avant les playoffs
qui se joueront potentiellement enfin
mais pour le club élan courtois du
basket à présent et trappes qui chutent
wiki chute face au premier de la
division le levallois sporting club
défaite 59 à 54 pour les trappistes qui
évolue à domicile
c'est la quatrième défaite pour le fc
trappes en 15 matches mais pas de
panique le reste le club reste troisième
au classement avant d'affronter son
homologue yvelinois marly le roi qui vit
une saison plus délicate dernier au
classement ils ont subi un revers de
plus ce samedi sur le parquet de
l'équipe de deux roues et enfin du
handball et on commence à s'inquiéter
pour les féminines de monty bretenoux
oui la défaite une de plus ce week-end
en bretagne contre le rose hand qui
alourdit le bilan d inhumaine dans cette
division 2 nationale 2 le score 27 à 25
c'est le septième match de rang sans
victoire michael pour le club qui n'a
plus connu le succès depuis le 2 octobre
dernier c'était face à issy paris savent
quand ça commence à remonter quand même
écouter garçons ça jouer en nationale 3
mais le chesnay yvelines handball qui
réalise une bonne saison s'est incliné
face à un concurrent direct
wattrelos c' est pas waterleau michael
clubs originaires des hauts de france
plus précisément de la métropole
lilloise frontalier avec la belgique les
chirurgiens géographique c'est sage
avoir quelques précisions puisque la
division au final le grande
géographiquement les chaînés tirs n'ont
pas réussi à rivaliser et perdre cinq
points une perte de cinq points 27 à 22
bilan du club en douze journées sept
victoires et quatre défaites dans une
poule 4 de nationale 3 très serré et où
rien n'est encore joué merci à bixente
pour toutes ces précisions vous retrouve
la semaine prochaine bien évidemment
michael chaque lundi on vous retrouve
alors va maintenant à parler des jeux
olympiques d'hiver de pékin vous allez
me dire que cela ne concerne a priori
pas à les yvelines et bien si chez une
ancienne plaisir aux 110 claire va
participer à l'événement à planétaire
cet ancien pistard de l'équipe de france
qui a déjà participé aux jo de 2012 et
2016 participer cette fois ci aux jo
d'hiver en bobsleigh à deux elle sera la
remplaçante du duo féminin elle nous
explique pourquoi elle s'est lancée dans
cette discipline
quand je faisais du vélo c'est mon frère
qui m'entrainait et en fait on délirait
france parti d'un délire où on disait
ben toi donc lui tu pilotera et puis moi
je pousserai et est en fait voilà j'ai
voulu vraiment tester ce que ça faisait
une descente de bob donc
voilà j'ai contacté la pilote margot boc
et puis donc ça c'était pendant le
confinement donc au printemps en 2020
moi c'était vraiment d'abord dans un but
c'était plaisir quoi vraiment découverte
et au final j'ai accroché tout de suite
[Musique]
qualités physiques c'est les mêmes parce
qu'il faut être à la fois fort rapide
donc puissant mais par contre je passe
d'un vélo donc un sport portée
ben c'est de la course à pied en fait
pour s'entraîner on fait de la
musculation et de l'athlétisme du sprint
et là par contre c'est enfin moi j'ai
jamais couru de ma vie il a fallu que
j'apprenne à courir
enfin savoir voilà bien pousser bien
monter le genou la poste du pied au sol
c'est plein de petits détails mais c'est
hyper technique la course c'est très
très technique donc c'était vraiment un
j'allais dire un pari un défi énorme
quoi
sélectionné en tant que remplaçante donc
c'est vrai que de ce côté là je suis un
petit peu déçu parce que je voulais
titulaire mais c'est comme ça c'est le
sport on a fait des tests de sélection
et ça c'est pas passer pour un petit peu
plus de 2 centièmes donc donc c'est un
peu rageant mais bon c'est comme ça et
moi mon objectif
ça va être de soutenir l'équipe et puis
d'être d'être présente si des fois ça se
passe mal malheureusement pour pour la
titulaire en fait il faut absolument que
je reste en forme et que je reste
comment dire performante
en golf après à 2 ans à d'absence l'open
de france sera bien de retour du 22 au
25 septembre sur les greens du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
le rendez-vous aura un sponsor titre le
groupe casu spécialisé dans la vente de
voitures en ligne une bonne nouvelle
pour l'événement qui aura une dotation
de 3 millions d'euros le double de
l'édition 2019 tv 68 vous propose
maintenant de découvrir un champion
d'exception à christopher 6 le cavalier
international évinois remporté une
médaille de bronze aux derniers jeux
olympiques de tokyo nous sommes allés à
sa rencontre à gaz rend regarder
[Musique]
aujourd'hui tv 78 et un gaz rend pour
rencontrer christopher 6 lecavalier a
remporté une brillante médaille de
bronze aux derniers jo de tokyo
[Musique]
christopher 6 et donc à mais un côté
alors avant de parler de votre palmarès
et de cette brillante médaille de bronze
que vous a remporté aux jo de tokyo on
va revenir sur votre parcours alors vous
êtes né en
1985 à longjumeau on est seul et vous
avez débuté dans un pot les clubs en
essonne à l'âge de 7 ans c'est bien ça
exactement j'ai commencé au val saint
germain au centre équestre de la licorne
qui était à l'époque dirigée par jean
françois laurent voilà j'ai fait mes
premiers cours d'équitation là-bas à
poney puis après passer tranquillement à
cheval en grandissant alors vos paroles
n'étaient pas cavalier il faut le
préciser absolument pas ma mère était
comptable et mon père travailler dans
une entreprise de machines automatisées
donc rien à voir avec les faux et du
coup le déclic c'est à quel âge à quel
âge vous avez voulu faire la compétition
15 ans je crois ouais c'est autour de
l'adolescence 15 16 ans ou vraiment j'ai
fait mes premiers concours amateur et et
ça m'a vraiment passionné donc donc
c'est à ce moment là je me suis dit que
j'aimerais bien tenter dans ce milieu là
est percé à haut niveau et vous donnez
professionnels à 21 ans c'est bien ça
oui je commence à me professionnaliser à
21 ans j'ai acquérir une jument
me permettant de commencer a atteint les
épreuves internationales donc donc c'est
à partir de cette période là que je suis
devenu professionnel du milieu votre
entourage vous a poussé peut-être
vous lancez comme professionnel alors on
va pas dire qu'ils m'ont poussée qui
n'ont pas freiné non plus
il connaissait un petit peu la dureté de
ce milieu là et que ma percée c'est pas
si facile faire du haut niveau c'est
assez compliqué donc qui m'ont aidée
comme il pouvait on va pas dire qu'ils
m'ont poussé il aurait peut-être préféré
que je fasse plus d'études et que ce
soit médecin ou avocat mais mais moi ça
m'intéresse pas et oui ça demande
beaucoup d'investissement j'imagine
c'est chronophage ces sept jours sur
sept c'est douze heures par jour c'est
si on veut si on veut réussir à percer
le haut niveau c'est exigeant donc faux
faut sans cesse travailler renouveler
son piquet de chevaux enfin se remettre
en question faire des stages aller en
compétition c'est c'est eh ouais mais
c'est beaucoup de temps et vous avez
créé ces écuries s'étaient en 2015 ici à
gaz rend pourquoi les yvelines
les yvelines c'est vrai que c'est quand
même porteur dans le milieu du cheval il
ya beaucoup d'écuries
c'est près de la ville et puis en même
temps c'est quand même assez rural et
j'ai mis du temps à trouver cet endroit
là j'ai cherché pendant presque deux ans
moi je me basais à limours dans le 91 je
voulais pas trop m'éloigner parce que
j'avais des clients déjà la barre donc
je m'étais dit à 35 40 kilomètres à la
ronde fallait que je trouve un endroit
et et c'est vrai que je suis tombé sur
cette écurie c'est vraiment une terre
d'équitation les yvelines ah bah oui oui
c'est une terre d'équitation il ya des
écuries tous les 10 kilomètres il ya
beaucoup de professionnels ce qui est
bien c'est moi je pense que quand il ya
beaucoup de personnes dans un milieu
basse est assez porteur
et puis en plus ça va être encore plus
une terre l'équitation parce que les
jeux de paris seront à versailles donc
versailles dans 78 donc c'est vrai que
c'est quand même assez incroyable ces
écuries c'est vraiment l'endroit idéal
pour performer au haut niveau ici je
sais pas si c'est l'endroit idéal parce
que l'endroit idéal gelé dans ma tête
mais j'ai pas les moyens de me le
financer donc j'aimerais avoir plus de
surface
ce qui n'est pas facile à trouver en
ile-de-france l'hectare est dur à
trouver mais
c'est un très bon outil de travail voilà
on est tout est assez condensé on n'est
pas trop loin des grands axes pour aller
en compétition parce que mine de rien on
passe du temps sur la route
donc il ya des gros avantages idéal non
mais
performant oui et vous avez un cheval
qui a fait beaucoup parler de lui ces
derniers mois totem debré sait comment
ça s'est passé cette histoire avec ce
cheval je crois que c'est assez
particulier bah c'est assez particulier
parce que ce cheval là
je les rencontre et parce que c'était le
cheval d'une de mes clientes qui est
toujours la propriétaire d'ailleurs mais
c'est elle qui le montait en compétition
donc
moi je la coach et je l'entends concours
je la faisais travailler avec ce cheval
là donc
donc c'est comme ça je l' ai connu et
puis après cette personne-là a fait des
études d'avocat et il n'avait plus trop
le temps de monter donc ses parents
m'ont demandé de prendre le relais de
ressortir le cheval en concours pour le
commercialiser le vendre donc c'est ce
que j'ai fait et puis et puis les
concours se sont un peu enchaîné au
départ sur un niveau intermédiaire et le
cheval a répondu présent et était était
vraiment très performant et la montée en
niveau et les propriétaires ont décidé
de garder parce qu'ils sont prêtés au
jeu de la compétition et de venir le
voir sur les plus beaux terrains
d'europe ça les a vraiment amusé est ce
ce lien du coup avec un cheval qui n'est
pas le vôtre à à la base c'est assez
particulier dans le monde de
l'équitation ou pas vraiment non c'est
pas particulier c'est notre métier de
nous adapter aux chevaux avec leurs
qualités et leurs défauts alors c'est
vrai quand on les forme des quatre en
bas c'est plus facile je parle là moi
j'ai commencé à le monter à dix ans
après je me suis très vite bien entendu
avec donc tout a été très vite mais ça
peut prendre plus de temps
mais c'est assez courant ça peut arriver
et qu'est ce qui fait que ça marche
finalement avec un cheval
ces deux caractères qui sont compatibles
ou pas un cheval très bon cheval peut
très bien fonctionner avec un cavalier
moins bien avec un autre même si les
deux cavaliers sont très bons
on a tous un peu nos préférences de
caractère c'est un couple en fait hein
c'est comme comme deux êtres humains
il y en a qui aiment bien il faut avec
du caractère d'autres thèmes des chevaux
avec un peu moins de caractère il n'y a
pas trop de ya pas trop de règles c'est
des affinités qui se créent en fait
alors on va continuer à parler de votre
parcours christopher 6 et de cette
médaille de bronze que vous avez
remporté à tokyo mais juste avant on va
regarder à ce reportage notre
journaliste mathilde de franck ou
spécialistes des chevaux a passé une
heure avec vous regardez comme vous le
savez aujourd'hui on est dans les
écuries de christopher 6 alors moi je
suis passionnée d'équitation j'en fais
depuis que je suis toute petite et
aujourd'hui et va on va essayer de
tenter de savoir comment décrocher une
médaille olympique le parti
[Musique]
bon alors comment ça s'est passé cette
première séance de saut depuis les jo de
tokyo mais moi je suis très content il
n'a pas oublié comment on faisait pas
vous repasser au dessus des barres
effectivement la dernière fois qu'il
avait sauté un obstacle c'était à tokyo
il a eu une grande pause j'ai pris le
parti de le faire un vrai break pour
qu'ils récupèrent de cette échéance là
là maintenant les jours commencent à
être comptés avant le début de saison
2022 donc faut s'y remettre et voilà
j'ai pris mon temps parce que c'est un
très bon sauteur il n'a pas besoin de
sauter beaucoup avant le premier
concours
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
astuces de pros je sais pas est ce que
vous avez des manies est ce que vous
faites des choses régulière un côté
enfin travail que vous faites tous les
jours est-ce que vous avez des petites
astuces de champion olympique
déjà alors je sais pas s'il ya beaucoup
d'astuces mais je faux travaille
pratiquement tous les jours ils ont un
jour mais off par semaine ou là ils
n'ont pas la selle sur le dos ils vont
que au paddock mais sinon on monte
dessus 6 jours sur 7 et après on varie
beaucoup le travail par contre ils vont
alterner entre du travail sur le
dressage du travail à l'obstacle des
extérieurs où ils ont juste aller se
balader et puis après il ya aussi les
les préparations les galops pour la mise
en sillonnant souffle à conditions et
tout ça donc j'essaye vraiment de varier
le plus possible pour pas que le cheval
il soit blasé par le travail en fait
plus on va varier plus on va varier le
travail plus il va être content de
travailler voilà maintenant vous savez
tout pour devenir champion olympique ou
presque parce que je pense qu'il ya une
sacrée dose de talent à avoir tout de
même
[Musique]
superbe séquence avec mathilde de franck
ou alors on va maintenant parler des
jeux olympiques de tokyo vous avez
participé à l'événement alors que vous
étiez à la base en remplaçant racontez
nous bah oui j'étais quatrième donc
premier réserviste l annonce de la
sélection
voilà une petite déception au départ
forcément avec les résultats qu'on nous
avions fait avec totem durant les deux
dernières années nous espérions nous
espérions être dans les trois titulaires
le nouveau le format a changé cette
année pour les jeux donc le
sélectionneur voulait des cavaliers qui
avait déjà fait les jeux olympiques donc
forcément moi ce n'était pas le cas
c'est pour ça que j'ai été j'étais en
tête et quatrième sur la première ligne
premier listing et puis lors de la
première semaine de préparation il ya
des cavaliers thibault valette qui son
cheval était un petit peu moins bien
physiquement donc tout le staff a décidé
de jeter l'épongé c'est là où j'ai
intégré l'équipe première et ce n'est
pas trop dur justement de s'organiser à
la dernière minute avec total de blessés
non parce qu'en tant que quatrième toute
façon je prenais l'avion je devais aller
là bas donc toutes les affaires étaient
déjà préparés mois voilà pour pour moi
j'allais là-bas je couvrais où je
courais pas je savais pas encore mais
dans tous les cas toute la logistique
était mise en place pour pour qu'il
prenne l'avion et que j'aille passé les
quinze jours à tokyo quand c'était quoi
finalement les jeux un avis pour vous
c'était un rêve l'aboutissement
peut-être d'une carrière bon allez jeux
olympiques c'est le rêve de tout sportif
poncin c'est un événement à part on
connaît les championnats d'europe on
connaît les championnats du monde donc
donc voila mais les jeux olympiques
c'est
vivre au village olympique c'est
partager des moments avec d'autres
sportifs
qui font pas du tout notre force et d
échanger c'est différent vous allez donc
remporté une médaille de bronze là bas
est-ce que vous vous attendiez à
performer avant de partir
on est et on voulait vraiment être dans
les cinq premiers au final
après
une médaille quand on va aux jeux on a
forcément envie de ramener deux
médailles ça c'est quelque chose c'est
une envie vraiment c'est vraiment une
grosse envie par contre après on sait
que tout peut arriver
les scores sont toujours très serrés le
monde petit pépin peut faire basculer
une nation dans le fond du classement
donc vous pour réussir un petit peu
interprété à s'adapter à tout moment et
c'est ça qui rend les choses un peu plus
difficiles que sur un concours lambda
alors la consécration arrive le 2 août 1
vous avez monte donc sur la troisième
marche du podium dans l'épreuve du
concours complet à par équipes c'était
quoi qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans
votre tête et bat déjà quand j'ai fini
parce que je suis passe en dernier donc
quand j'ai fini le parcours
je cherchais mon résultat absolument
pour être sûr que j'avais commis aucune
faute parce que dans la concentration
sera pas forcément content et je
n'arrivais pas à avoir un bon résultat
parce qu'avec les projecteurs et tout le
voilà jeté un peu déboussolée et en
sortie de piste mes camarades mes
coéquipiers tout le staff français m'ont
sauté dessus et là j'ai compris qu'on
avait une médaille je vous savez pas
laquelle mai mais voilà je me suis dit
ça y est le boulot est fait on peut
respirer un coup c'est fini quoi vous
avez l'impression peut-être d'avoir
réalisé quelque chose de grand je crois
que ce n'est arrivé que que qu'à quatre
reprises dans l'histoire de la france
aux jeux olympiques en 68 c'était la
première et du coup la dernière en 2021
est ce que c'est quelque chose de grand
que vous avez accompli bah on marque
l'histoire en fait c'est ça qui est
impressionnant c'est que effectivement
concours complet il ya eu quatre
médailles donc donc ça fait pas beaucoup
mine de rien c'est
et c'est quelque chose qui est difficile
à avoir donc quand on en a une on la
garde précieusement la serre très fort
dans notre main et on dit celle-là je
veux pas la perdre et comment vous avez
fêté ça du coup cette médaille de bronze
eh ben on a fêté ça assez tranquillement
là bas parce qu'on est parti assez
rapidement le lendemain de la
compétition était dans l'avion et puis
on a fini tard le lundi soir par contre
on a fêté ça en rentrant avec mes amis
mes propriétaires c'était voilà c'était
un bon moment et du coup l'avenir si
c'est quoi pour vous et total de blessés
ben l'avenir à court terme donc cette
année il ya les championnats du monde
les championnats du monde qui se passe à
prato ni en italie déroulera au mois de
septembre et
l'année prochaine il y aura les
champions d'europe au haras du pin en
france voilà et forcément 2024
les jeux de paris reste mon objectif
premier alors c'est sûr que c'est dans
deux ans et demi c'est court et c'est
long à la fois ses cours pour former un
cheval c'est long pour regarder en bonne
santé donc je garde ça en tête
maintenant je me faut pas non plus
penser qu'à ça parce que sinon on vit
plus mais c'est vraiment rangé dans un
coin de ma tête comme tokyo étaient
rangés et le but c'est qu'il aille à
paris est le plus beau truc que
j'aimerais faire c'est lui enlever la
selle et qui prenne sa retraite à paris
et vous l'avez dit c'est dans ça sera
dans les mines les épreuves vont se
dérouler à à versailles est ce que c'est
une source de motivation supplémentaire
sachant que vous êtes dans les yvelines
vous basse et oui c'est forcément courir
courir dans son département courir dans
son pays dans sa région c'est quelque
chose d'incroyable de château de
versailles aussi ben voilà ça va être un
lieu magique j'ai coché vu quelques
images des images de synthèse comment ça
allait comment ça allait être ça va
juste être somptueux c'est s'arrête un
cadre magique donc forcément c'est une
motivation supplémentaire
et du coup ça sera quoi votre plus grand
rêve à à paris médaille d'or là
forcément vous avez le bronze ces
argents war en fait c'est ça une
médaille mais olympiques alors forcément
si c'est lors c'est le graal après une
médaille olympique c'est quand même très
beau donc
déjà les faire et essayer de ramener
ramener une médaille deux pour son pays
ce serait ce serait génial qu'est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour les
prochains mois les prochaines années
restent à faire 6 et ben que totem reste
en pleine forme jusqu'à paris et qu'ils
fassent chanter la marseillaise à tout
le monde à versailles merci à vous
christopher 6 et on vous le souhaite
[Musique]
vous l'aurez compris christopher 6 à
d'énormes ambitions et pourquoi pas une
médaille d'or aux jeux olympiques de
paris en 2024 c'est la fin de cette
émission merci l'avoir suivi à bientôt
sur tv 78
[Musique]